foreign
and I am from Fairfax County Virginia
when the pandemic hit that's when we
found out things that our children were
learning or not learning a few of us
parents banded together because we
thought that you know educational
excellence in marriages all that matters
not the color of your skin and so we
formed the Coalition for TJ and we gave
each other support and we reached out
across the aisle local government state
government anyone who would who would
lend us their support and and one of
them was the then candidate Glenn
youngin and he completely supported us
and I supported him and
um I I was a very vocal parent advocate
and when he asked me to be on the board
of education I I was thrilled
foreign
to an audience as inclusive as our
Virginia is you cannot reference the
Declaration of Independence and
Constitution as remarkable documents
without also acknowledging that they
contain fundamental flaws of enshrining
slavery and limiting the protections
that they provided for only to White
property men I I just I can't I'm not
comfortable with that language I'm not
comfortable with the language of of
centralized government planning in the
form of Socialism or communist political
systems is incompatible with democracy I
would I would concede on communism but
there are plenty of governments that
call themselves socialist democratic
governments so you know what is
socialism compatible with democracy that
would be a great debate to have in a a
12th grade government civics class
the Declaration and the Constitution I
think it's their remarkable documents I
I don't do not believe
the Declaration and Constitution
enshrines slavery not that they limit
protections to White property men as far
as the Socialism or communist
I think socialism is just about as bad
as as communism socialism is like the
nanny state which
predominates in so many parts of the
world it's it co-ops the important
decisions belonging to families and
individuals I I
come from a country which used to be
more socialistic now than you know but
then than it is now
but it's it is it creates dearth
dependency and depression somebody had
to jump in and and challenge that
Viewpoint that you know America is Great
America's founding documents are great
and I do believe that socialism
um is very destructive coming from a
country which
was founded as a socialist country you
know and it continues to be in India uh
I I just disagree I think that giving
people their their freedoms in in every
way makes for a better better citizenry
and being allowed to to
um to decide things for ourselves rather
than
red rather than you know the government
you know America won't be great if if it
uh doesn't you know is isn't allowed to
keep its independent uh streak uh and
freedom of thought
I'm very disappointed to not get to not
be confirmed I thought people celebrated
diversity whether it's diversity of
thought University of viewpoint or
diversity of
you know any of the many characteristics
I am
shocked I thought such a you know
tactics were
uh you know sort of reserved for not for
America other countries
only in America can a common person be
heard raise his voice and be heard and
be part of the process and I will
continue to fight uh for education for
our children
foreign